Let's go to let's go to Shiv from Boston.
We haven't heard from Shiv from Boston for
like 10 months.
Shiv.
How's it going, my friend?
Is going well, David, how's it going with
you?
Good.
Great.
Well, I guess I have two options for a question.
One is on like creeping authoritarianism from
the state and the other is on like right wing
views of people both in response to the virus.
I don't know if one is a topic.
We rather discuss.
Let's do the second one, because I did a lot
this week on authoritarianism already.
Cool.
So in terms of the right wing views, I guess
I got a couple examples.
So my dad is a bit of an elitist intellectual
type and his view and the virus, is that like,
oh, it's an IQ test, right?
Because the people who are too dumb to listen
to the authorities that we trust are gonna
go get the virus.
Right.
Something like that.
And then I have like more at my desk.
I like right wing, the traditional sense things
to say and stuff, but Democrat or whatever.
But then I also have people from my work who
are more conventionally right wing like rurals
or my rover and Jaguar where they're just
like all the stupid people are going to going
to die in this.
And I guess the essence of the topic in my
pet cover thing was the nature of a person
to say in response to this crisis that all
my beliefs are correct and that is why it's
going to work after me.
There is all that simple.
I don't like we'll be punished.
And it kind of waste to that thing outside
my authoritarianism because I see this as
a very easy tool to divide people.
I mean, you're literally isolating people
into their homes.
You can't interact with them and people.
And your form of media is just gonna tell
you that whatever you're doing is right and
everyone else is wrong.
And I kind of point to the spring breakers
thing where it's like spring breakers.
Well, honestly, they don't sound great.
They might be dumb.
They're the cause of the problem as opposed
to maybe the people running things.
So I want to get your thought on that sort
of response to a couple different things.
I mean, one, so.
So the first thing about it's the dumb people
who will get the virus and die to sort of
Darwinian natural selection thing.
The problem is it doesn't work with something
that's contagious and that's that.
I would feel differently to say, hey, you
know what?
If some people really don't take this seriously
and they don't care.
They're only putting themselves at risk.
Go let them get it and die.
That's the reason we can't do that, is because
they're spreading it to others who are doing
the right things.
So I get that instinct.
But unfortunately, because it's a contagious
virus, it just doesn't work.
And I would feel differently if it did.
It's not that I would root for anyone to die,
but I would have to some degree say the government
can't force people to stay alive if they're
only endangering themselves and no one else,
then let them go have at it.
That's not the case because they're getting
they're getting other people sick.
That's that's sort of number one.
Number two, it for me was one of the things
that scares me is when I see people.
Completely sure that they know exactly what's
going on with the virus, either that they
fully understand how it should be treated
or they fully understand how it spreads.
What I've found and I read so much about this
every day, I'm looking at clinical trials,
you know, all of this different stuff.
Every day I come away saying, wow, there's
so much we don't yet know about this.
And so I would be skeptical of anyone who
is following what's going on or not following
it and thinks that they really know what's
going on.
What we really seem to be learning is how
little we understand about this so far.
Yes, that's right.
Oh, my completely breaking up now it seems
that we've.
Your connection has gone nuclear.
So I'm going to let you go.
But I really do appreciate the question.
And it was well asked and I didn't even because
I like you, I didn't even ask you about that
weird speaker phone noise that was coming
from your phone.
But next time, make a note of it.
Make a note of it.
Excellent phone calls today.
Maybe the best slate of phone calls that we've
had, Pat.
Make a note of it.
We will go to a break.
I apologize.
I wasn't able to.
Wasn't able to get to everybody.
But we will take calls again.